[Musique]
bonsoir à vous jean pierre colombet ce
porte-parole du syndicat policier unis
et cyril huet land in délégué national
adjoint du syndicat pénitentiaire
sps alors d'abord on va regarder cette
réaction du président d'honneur de la
ligue des droits de l'homme qui s'est
exprimé hier chez nos confrères à 2 m6
ce sont des mesures qui sont extrêmement
restrictives de liberté
nous avions émis les plus grandes
réserves sur les algorithmes
ce n'est pas sûr de l'efficacité il n'y
a pas de rapport nous sommes vraiment
dans une situation dans laquelle nous
nous sacrifions des libertés sans
forcément nous en rendre compte
est ce qu'on sacrifie nos libertés
individuelles au nom de davantage de
sécurité
jean-pierre colombiès écoutez ce que ce
que m'évoque l'énoncé des nouvelles
mesures des nouvelles propositions du
gouvernement c'est très simple je pense
qu'elles sont à la fois parfaitement
inutile dangereuse et révélatrice d'un
échec global surtout sur l'appréhension
du phénomène de la radicalisation dans
dans notre pays
inutile parce que je ne vois pas comment
on va pouvoir contrôler intercepté des
centaines de connexions vers des sites
que l'on qualifie de dangereux on fait
référence en cela des sites comme vous
trouvez également sur le dark web ou qui
sont diffusées par anciennement des
choux à al qaïda il lui était bien plus
courageux d'aller fouiller dans le dark
wave de neutraliser en amont ce qui est
attractif pour ceux qui veulent se
nourrir de cette culture mais hélas ça
nécessite d'aller plus loin avec les
fournisseurs d'accès et c'est une autre
démarche qui est qui nécessite un peu
plus de courage et je dirais 2
je dirais de volonté politique
elle est inutile parce que tout
simplement vous pouvez pas vous ne
pourrez pas surveiller des centaines de
mise en connexion sur dell ou tel site
on n'a pas le personnel on n'a pas les
ressources pour ça donc on est de mon
point de vue de ce point de vue là
dedans effet d'annonce que dans une
réalité opérationnelle s'est dit c'est
en même temps dangereux parce que si on
dirait on institutionnalise ce mode de
contrôle et de filtres mis dans les
mains d'un gouvernement qui aurait une
certaine tendance à jouer avec les
règles de la démocratie ça pourrait
s'avérer particulièrement périlleux et
sites en même temps très révélateur d'un
constat d'échec sur le terrain parce que
ce qui fait la force de la détection
d'un individu fragile et susceptible
d'être dangereux quand ton passage à
l'acte c'est tout simplement la présence
sur le terrain or cette présence sur le
terrain nous ne l'avons plus on a
sacrifié le principe de la du lien
social entre la police notamment et la
citoyenneté et ça on le paye cash le
paye très cher donc on veut substituer
cette absence de relations sur le
terrain qui est le ver il a
véritablement sources du renseignement
comme cela l'a été pendant des années on
veut y substituer une sorte de police ou
de renseignement 2.0 alors oui cette loi
comporte aussi d'autres volets pas
seulement les voiliers de surveillance
numérique vous êtes d'accord
cyril huet à l'envi sur l'aspect inutile
de la loi alors effectivement je ne vois
pas grand chose à rajouter vous dire mon
cher collègue de la police oui c'est mon
excuse qui m'exaspère c'est de voir ne
parle pas comme on dit on a l'impression
que de penser à vite vite parce que on
est encore un fonctionnaire qui et qui
malheureusement a été tué suite a dit
d'attentât et que jusqu'à présent rien
n'a été fortement mis en place donc
voila moi je suis peinée par table après
je reviendrai pas sur ce que dit mon
confrère
effectivement il ya il ne pouvait me
prendrai t pas avec des algorithmes
qu'on va pouvoir et les talents des
surtout avec une présence humaine et des
moyens
des moyens matériels et les matches sont
des moyennes là dessus plutôt que des
algorithmes qui vont être de toute
manière détournée par d'autres d'autres
manières à chaque fois c'est pour
mathieu se détournent de toute manière
ce projet de loi pour lutter contre le
terrorisme
il intervient après le crime de
rambouillet jean castex affirme que ce
n'est pas un texte de circonstance qu'il
a bien été préparée avant qu'en pensez
vous est-ce que tout de même ce hasard
de calendrier
il est il vous interpelle jean pierre
colombiès très honnêtement je me suis
déjà exprimé à l'issue de ce drame
tout de suite après en disant qu une
fois de plus dont vaud systématiquement
dans le piège de la gesticulation du
discours et de la posture et jamais
jamais depuis des années maintenant
jamais on ne prend véritablement le je
dirais le taureau par les cornes si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi
il ya un vrai problème de fond il ya un
problème sur le terrain qui est
parfaitement identifié il n'y a pas de
faux pas une goutte de cristal pour
savoir ce qui se passe dans certains
secteurs ce qui se passe dans la tête de
ceux qui passent à l'acte on sait
parfaitement comment ça se produit mais
on ne prend pas les véritables mesures
pour pas la la la la la la mesure et je
dirais les décisions qui pourraient
neutraliser en amont ce qui est en train
de se passer et genre et j'en veux pour
preuve une disposition vous allez
peut-être évoqué c'est celle du suivi
médico-judiciaire psycho judiciaire
enfin là c'est à mourir de rire face ici
on peut imaginer qu'on puisse rire dans
de telles circonstances
mais on veut appliquer à des gens qui
sont convaincus d'une fois qu'ils sont
des croyants tout simplement des
croyants exalté mais des croyants quand
même qu'on veut appliquer à ces
personnages des règles du suivi
psychiatrique
car faut qu'on m'explique est ce qu'un
croyant exaltés ou pas est un malade
mental et est-ce qu'on peut résoudre le
problème des années venue de ce même
ceux d'autres djihadistes par des règles
qu'on applique aux pervers sexuel
franchement je sais tu as c'est assez
désespérant de voir que les propositions
du et des gouvernements parce que ce
n'est pas le seul se limite à des
mesurettes ou à des mesures totalement
limitée dans le temps et surtout qu'ils
n'ont aucune efficacité concrètes parce
que en fait on ne contrôle pas vraiment
les personnes dont on sait qu'elles sont
extrêmement dangereuses ce texte
cyril huet landing il il représente en
fait c'est un texte qui fait suite à des
dispositions qui sont déjà existantes
dans le cadre de la loi
renseignements de juillet 2015 celle sur
la sécurité intérieure et la lutte
contre le terrorisme aussi puisque vous
dites que c'est justement une loi qui
est inutile comment est ce qu'il aurait
fallu s'y prendre pour compléter les
dispositifs qui sont déjà en vigueur
pour compléter la problématique n'est
pas de compliquer qui essaie de mettre
des moyens humains des ressources de la
formation de la structure et voilà il
faut on habite au dail pour se servir de
notre dame et il faut se servir des
déformations de terrain et au cas des
étuis l'algorithme parce que moi qui
fabrique du doigt et tu avais pas
forcément te contourner et pathé pas
quelque chose qui n'y ont pas comment
j'en suis très très pertes à quoi et à
voyez vraiment aujourd'hui d'une
pression on habite tendu quelque chose
parce qu'il fallait le prendre effet le
père guy top parce que depuis les
derniers attentats
il ya pas grand chose finalement en
termes de sécurité
le premier ministre qui a rappelé que
cette loi elle répondait aussi et le
ministre de l'intérieur aussi gérald
darmanin elle a précisé que c'est une
loi qui répondait à de nouvelles
problématiques des profils particuliers
qui sont de plus en plus jeune des actes
isolés
jean-pierre columbia ce nom mais la
foire faut arrêter de se moquer du monde
on découvre pas aujourd'hui qu'on a un
nouveau profil de terroristes on sait
depuis des années
je rappelle que mohamed merah même s'il
a été formé au yémen il est tout seul il
est bas accompagné dans le cas de ses
actes en tout cas il n'est pas
accompagné d'une bande il a pas autour
de lui
je vais dire est une structure qu'on
peut comparer à celle qui a précédé les
attentats du bataclan ou d'un an mais et
puis très très sincèrement ça fait des
années qu'on étudie le phénomène du
passage à l'acte on sait qu'il ya un
terrorisme low cost qui s'est développée
en france et ailleurs d'ailleurs on l'a
vu au niveau des attentats commis en
allemagne ou en angleterre donc on a
affaire à des gens qui se radicalise
effectivement sans avoir besoin de
logistique qui prennent qui prennent des
bhutto qui prennent des voitures
conformément je dirais aux préceptes de
développé par day qui invite les
croyants à rentrer en guerre contre les
mécréants à l'aide de tout ce qui peut
leur tombait sous la main je je je fais
court mais c'est pas nouveau c'est pas
du tout une forme tombé du placard c'est
quelque chose qui des geeks qui étaient
déjà connus qui est déjà connu à la fois
des services de renseignements mais tout
simplement connu de ceux qui
s'intéressent un tant soit peu au
phénomène de la radicalisation dans ce
pays
découvrir aujourd'hui des gens passent à
l'acte tout seul et se radicalise face à
leur écran d'ordinateur
excusez-moi si si le premier ministre
m'aperçois qu'en ce moment c'est que
c'est un petit peu
il ya quelque chose qui ne colle pas
trop dans les rouages de transmission de
l'information
sylvette l'envi
le garde des sceaux il a aussi précisé
qu'il s'agissait de renforcer le suivi
des personnes qui sont condamnées pour
des faits de terrorisme
ça concerne un peu moins d'une centaine
de détenus qui ont été condamnés et
qu'ils vont sortir selon lui aurait
effectivement on a on a à peu près on a
une trentaine de détenus incarcérés dans
notre structure spécifique
il y en a très peur quand on n'a pas les
quartiers pour handicapés a
effectivement elle tape et a fait
quelques années qu'ils sont chez nous
donc tellement donné on va les relâcher
est ce qu'il faudrait éthérée la vraie
question c'est qui tenta un tir à bhl
c'est encore autre chose tu as été un
sujet sur lequel il faut qu'on arrête de
faire l'autruche qu'on se penche
vraiment dessus parce que on va en faire
quoi maintenant option sortie et ils
sont prolongées il est question de
prolonger les mesures individuelles de
contrôle oui alors il est proche de
troyes 2-1 aura dedans et donc une année
plus ça va faire quoi
c'est votre salle à l'abri question
parce que la problématique est le genre
de détenus et que ce ne sont pas des
détenus qui t'ont réinsérables il faut
vraiment qu'on se mettre en tête qu'on a
affaire à des gens qui ne sont pas
réalisables
ce n'est pas possible merci d'ailleurs
si je peux me permettre rapidement très
rapidement très rapidement sur les
contrôles sur des dispositifs de
contrôle comme je le disais tout à
l'heure comparables ou fijais des
pervers sexuels
ils sont obligés de pointer de déclarer
leur adresse mais ça n'empêche pas
personne ne les contrôle dans leurs
allées et venues au quotidien donc il ya
des points de suspension et des points
d'interrogation complet dans le cadre de
de leur vie de leur vie personnelle donc
au c'est totalement insuffisant
totalement insuffisant et puis surtout
en décalage complet avec la réalité
merci à vous jean pierre colombet haas
porte-parole du syndicat policier ni
merci à vous également cyril huet
lambine délégué national adjoint du
syndicat pénitentiaire
sps